pour de nombreux amateurs de cuisine la
cuisinière au gaz est incontournable
d'ailleurs dans la majorité des
restaurants on les utilise mais on
apprenait en janvier dans une étude de
l'université stanford que les cuisinière
au gaz contribuerait au réchauffement
climatique selon l'étude les 43 millions
de cuisinière au gaz aux etats-unis
produisent en méthane l'équivalent des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre que
produisent 500 mille voitures par an 500
milles c'est beaucoup une cinquantaine
de villes en californie et la ville de
new york interdisent ou écart diront
bientôt le branchement au gaz de
nouvelles constructions
on a demandé à quelqu'un d'expérience
s'il pouvait se passer de sa cuisinière
au gaz
daniel beesley avec un grand chef qui
disons le à quelques années d'expérience
derrière les fourneaux voulez vous
savoir vraiment le nombre d'années 44
les chiens aime beaucoup sa cuisinière
au calme comme quelque chose d'organique
quand on cuisine avec des flandres on
sent la chaleur sur notre corps vers
leurs rapports avec la flamme
cet achat en votre cuisine d'amour entre
le matin observant que ma tête en garde
partout dans cuisine
bralima nation volatile
justement selon l'étude de lumière ce
testing prude 75% de ses émanations sont
produites quand les cuisinières sont
permis parce qu'il ya toujours de
petites fuites de gaz
ce sont des émanations de méthane qui
peuvent inclure du monoxyde de carbone
et les oxyde nitrique responsable de
plusieurs maladies respiratoires
conclusion la plaque à induction est un
choix plus écolo est meilleure pour la
santé je comprends que c'est meilleur
pour la santé c'est plus écolo c'est
plus qu'aux responsables lorsque de se
bâtir un chaudron de sur l'induction 1
minute que tu retires la plaque et
porsche ont un enfant passe à côté mais
sa main dessus il va pas brûler
et qui dit nouvel outil dit période
d'adaptation quand on a travaillé
pendant bien des années avec le gaz
quand on pense à l'induction on est
vraiment nul mais du lait à bouillir
vous de voir le chaudron est en train de
renverser ça brûle très rapidement aussi
ça fait très très rapidement donc mois
les premières fois j'ai brûlé beaucoup
de choses j'en ai renversé des jaunes
est ce que le chef se sent prêt à
troquer le gaz pour l'électrique
autrement c'est dans l'air du temps de
penser à l'induction parce que en ce
moment on essaie d'éliminer les énergies
fossiles les émanations toxiques on fait
attention à ça on est carrément dans la
ligne à conduction j'ai objet de la boue
allez bon appétit au canada c'est
environ 9 % des ménages qui utilisent
une cuisinière au gaz à vancouver dès
2025 on interdira tout nouveau
branchement au gaz naturel toronto veut
bannir le gaz d'ici 2040 et à montréal
d'ici 2030 on veut réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de 55%
si vous aviez dans l'idée de vous
acheter une cuisinière au gaz bientôt
pensez-y ici elisa céret radio canada
montréal